It's time for Drew's News.
Your daily jiggle of that good news jello.
Whoa.
And with me at the desk...
I can't say jello without doing this.
His favorite jello flavor is red.
Rossi Ross Mathews.
(audience cheers)
Jello.
First up, the hardest working woman in showbiz
has done it again.
NME reports, Madonna's new live concert film
"Madame X" is out on Paramount Plus right now.
Cameras followed her on tour dates
for 75 days around the world,
and I was lucky enough to be in the audience
for the New York premiere.
Uh-huh, and I got to ask her a question.
Madonna.
(Ross laughs)
By the way, she would not approve of any of this goofiness.
I feel like she's so damn cool.
But I wanted to share the moment with you.
So take a look.
My question for you was, have you said no to anything
that you wish you had said yes to?
And what was that thing?
Ooh, that's a good one.
Good question.
Yeah, I was given the script to "The Matrix."
What?
I was offered
the role of Trinity.
You're kidding.
I read the script and I'm like,
this is the stupidest (beep) I've ever read in my life.
What?
I turned it down.
(audience laughing)
(Drew laughing)
Okay.
I'm sorry, do you know how cool it is
that you get to go to opening night
and you get to ask Madonna a question?
The truth is I used to be all up in the club with Madonna
and Sean back in the day.
So I've really known her most of my life
Of course.
But, she's also still Madonna
and I'm geeking out and freaking out.
But this concert film is really unlike other concert films.
It makes you feel like you've traveled to Europe,
and you're seeing exquisite performance art.
I felt like I had left the country
and gone to some beautiful place.
And she's wearing a black wig in it,
and the people in it are just...
It's really incredible.
Yeah, I met Madonna one time.
And?
Yeah, mm-hmm.
She goes like this and I like touched her hand,
and I felt like I was touched for the very first time.
(audience laughs)
(Drew laughs)
You were, Rossi. You were.
I was.
Well, okay, hey Drew, we've got a little follow-up for you.
You remember earlier this week, if you were watching,
we played a game of Chicago trivia,
and it was Chicago native Ike Barinholtz
versus Chicago Blackhawks' Jonathan Toews and Seth Jones.
The stakes were high, they did trivia,
and the loser agreed to be posted
on a huge Drew yellow billboard for all of Chicago to see.
And the loser kept their word.
Take a look at this.
I know. This is real.
This is not a mock up.
We love "The Drew Barrymore Show"
with the Chicago Blackhawks.
(audience cheering)
Guess what, Chicago?
We're coming for ya.
Oh yeah.
We're bringing the show to you.
So watch out, 'cause we're coming to town soon.
We love you.
(Ross laughs)
Chicago.
Stay tuned for that.
(upbeat bright music)